of the executive uh first agenda item is
attendances uh to note apologies from
councelor Joanne Harding um looking
around the room apart from councelor R
said who was on his way back I think
everyone else is present and correct so
moving on to item two I've not received
any interest any notice of Declarations
of Interest anyone wish to declare
anything okay item three questions from
the public there are no questions from
the public this time so with that we'll
move quickly on to item four which is
Matters from overview and scrutiny or
Council and I'm going to go first to
councelor David Aton and the events Old
Trafford task and finish group
report could you just check your
microphone
that that's
strange
yeah yeah thank thanks leader um yeah we
we did set up a task and finish group to
consider the impact uh of events and
match days at Old
Trafford uh we we did elect councelor
Lawrence Walsh to be chair of this uh
task and finish group unfortunately he
he's unable to attend tonight
um just to say that to get a grip of the
problems local residents who live and
work near to the
stadium um we sent out a survey early on
last year and we received
438 responses which is a a good sample
of of views uh and it wasn't it was no
surprise to those that live near there
or the counselors that represent that
area area that the main issues raised
was traffic and antisocial
parking and in light of that survey uh
results scrutiny produced a report and
12 uh
recommendations and I won't go into all
the recommendations because they're
there before you uh but there's one or
two interesting ones which I will
highlight um we we do have uh new
regulation power hours to set up Red
Line Red Road lines across some of our
roads around the stadium but where
antisocial car parking on Match days are
very
um uh you can see it every time you go
to a a United game or whatever but
hopefully we can deliver on this as soon
as possible um we need to encourage also
Manchester United to provide secure bike
storage at the stadium to increase
cycling as an option to driving uh
because you know 74,000 go there
regularly uh on Match days um and there
very little
s cycling spaces uh that that um you
know they they've produced at Old
Trafford so um yeah there there are a
couple of them but um I think um uh
tfgm um they they they are are looking
and have actually started a shutle
service um and we want to try to expand
that and I think put pressure on them to
uh continue to work to to have different
ways of transporting people to the
ground and so that's it uh and I hope
you know the executive considers all the
recommendations and look to actually uh
bring bring them live uh to to to that
area okay thank you councelor acted on
behalf of the executive we will
certainly take away the report um I
think you're absolutely right to observe
that this got a lot of public interest I
should really declare an interest as
someone that lives within the scope of
that area and I'm impacted by mat Day
event Day Parking as well I think it's
really good and it's important to say
that um Beyond this task and finish
group The Ward councils have uh have
secured some really good relationships
with the club and a couple of um good
actions have come off that already I
think believe around alliga in some
areas so you know there's some good
partnership work taking place between
Ward counselors and the club and I think
this helps us as we um as as we work
together with Manchester United and
improve experience for residents around
there so some some good suggestions in
there and we will take those away
consider them and then respond to you so
thank you for that are there any other
announcements or things you'd like to
raise Council
act thank you councilor but anything
from the health scy
committee yes thank you chair um the SC
committee had an informal session last
Wednesday 24th in the form of a workshop
with NHS GM NHS Representatives priority
are access and treatments uh and advice
and guidance
so into oning review
Tak thank you very much okay moving on
to um the minutes and I am happy to move
that the minutes from the 15th November
27th of November and 11th of December
are a correct record of the meetings all
those in
favor thank you and then on to item six
which is the infrastructure and
development in new Carrington so this is
a joint report from councel Liz Patel
and councelor Aiden Williams but I'll go
to councelor Liz Patel in first
instance thank you
leader this comprehensive report draws
together several interl planning and
funding matters relating to the delivery
of new highway infrastructure required
to support the development of new
Carrington and existing communities in
Partington Carrington and S West it's a
waight a weighty report from which I
will summarize the main points in order
to set out the current context of how
traffic council is proposing to deliver
what is a complex infrastructure project
it has been a historical ambition of
this local Authority and various
administrations to provide a new road
link which supplies additional capacity
to the existing a61 144 West of Banky
Lane a route that despite large scale
residential in Industrial Development
over decades remains largely unchanged
since the 19th century this has left
communities isolated with poor and
congested Highway links little access to
rail or metr Link services and an
infrequent and traffic impacted bus
service the route for what we currently
call the car Carrington relief Road was
safeguarded in the 2006 Trafford unitary
development plan and in 2012 the
Trafford course strategy identified
alongside proposals for new homes at the
former shell facility a new Carrington
relief Road funded by contributions from
related new development since those
policy decisions in the early 2000s it
has become clear that the cost of
delivering this route has been
underestimated and cannot be funded
solely by related development
contribution although improvements inter
junctions have been delivered over
recent years per permitted new
developments have relied on the existing
highways Network which is now operating
at
capacity in 2024 the delivery of
Carrington relief Road must be viewed in
the context of a wider new Carrington
master plan project as part of the
place's forone allocation and the
detailed Carrington transport strategy
which is attached to this report and for
which we are seeking approval of tonight
the area of new carington will become a
Focus become the focus of significant
growth in Trafford and GM and as such
needs to be afforded the appropriate
policy and funding
focus it is Our intention to deliver
through the adoption of places for
everyone and subsequent new Carrington
master plan a sustainable new community
covering Carrington Partington and S
West with high levels of internal
walking Cy and cycling provision
provision of internal local community
facilities including a primary school
and good public transport connection
including into the wider GM Network
whilst we acknowledge places for
everyone is not yet adopted following
its positive examination in public it's
important we proactively embark on
Master planning work ahead of its
potential adoption so at the end of 2023
Trafford Council embarked on an
important piece of work a new carington
master plan which is to be developed in
consultation with the community and key
stakeholders I attended the first round
of stakeholder and community group
meetings in December and believe it will
be a transparent and ultimately
constructive and positive piece of work
drawing together different views and
needs on what is required in
infrastructure terms PES for everyone
sets out the broad policy framework to
address the existing transport
constraints in order to support
significant housing and employment
growth this was explored in detail
during the public examination of
proposals last year further to this the
Carrington transport strategy sets out a
realistic short and long-term
policy policies which seek to address
standards of sustainable development as
set out by GM and
tfgm section 4.6 of this report shows
this in detail but broadly within new
Carrington we want to bring forward
accessible streets which prioritize
active travel a network of safe cycling
and walking routes using existing public
right of ways and potential use of
disused railway lines connections
between neighborhoods by overcoming
barriers such as the the redbrook water
course and the disused railway line
between eram and templey a sustainable
transport Corridor running east to west
along the disu railway lines to Erland
timley and alham bus in priority
infrastructure and bus service
improvement linking in with the GMB
Network and necessary improvements to
the existing Highway Network which is
the main subject of this
report section moving on through the
report section five sets out the project
management time scales costs and funding
breakdown for what is a significant and
complex local government infrastructure
project following consultation we intend
to submit a planning application for the
Carrington relief Road at the end of
this year in terms of funding we have an
upto-date position of the costs involved
of around 76.5 million pounds and we
have already secured significant funding
to take the project through to its
planning stages if we secure planning
permission we would be in a favorable
position to attract further further
funding going forward from both the
public and private sector broadly we
have a an already determined formula to
identify section 106 contributions from
developers and now that we have
completed payment for the Trafford Park
metr link extension we we will be
earmarking from the infrastructure
elements of the community infrastructure
Levy towards Carrington relief Road the
final Target for funding support is from
central government via the combined
Authority and we have already engaged
enged in Dialogue on that
strategy section six of the report looks
at an area potential constraints which I
feel highlights The Challenge and
Industrial nature of the sites around
Carrington it's important to note the
potential impact of costs and timetable
of pfas contaminants which are
relatively newly identified and have no
single readymade remediation approach
available we are already undertaking
work with the environment agency and
land owner Wayne Holmes to ident
identify a remediation
strategy it should be noted that in
relation to Peak deposits the approved
line of the Carrington relief road is
located some distance north of the
identified Peak deposits with around 2
kilometers of the route running through
the former shell petrochemical site and
as a result Pete is not considered to be
a significant
constraint finally I would like to
return to the planning considerations
impacting on the carington relief Road
and in particular how we as an authority
manage new development in the locality
ahead of the completion of the road and
and Adoption of the new Carrington
master plan which will provide a future
planning basis on which to secure
developer
contributions before the new Carrington
master plan is adopted there will be a
need to develop an interim approach to
contributions planning contributions
which recognizes the highway network has
reached capacity but that we could allow
developments to be approved in the short
term if they are subject to temporary
calculation of in infrastructure
contributions we will need to strike a
balance in terms of facilitating
development and investment into
Carrington and related de developer
contributions were the reality of the
impact on the network as it's operating
on the ground assuming all other
planning issues are satisfactorily
addressed with a proposal we will look
at three options in terms of an approach
to infrastructure option A approved
development but with an interim
contribution
to be replaced with a master plan
compliant contribution in due course
option b as above but subject to a
grampian condition linked to the de
delivery of infrastructure option C
refuse development because its temporary
impacts are too great or it obstruct
future infrastructure plans the merits
of every planning application are
different and each application will be
assessed as such on this issue please
note the recommendations in this report
invites the planning and development
committee to consider consider and
approve a detailed formula for inter
infrastructure
contributions in conclusion I would like
to thank officers led by Adrien Fisher
for progressing and presenting this
report it's complex and ambitious and
marks an important milestone in this
long-term project most of the
communities in Trafford Prosper because
they are well connected indeed many
people choose to live in Trafford
because they can access good schools
employment cultural activities the city
center Motorway links but this is
fundamentally not the case for some of
our communities Who Remain locked out of
that opportunity a project decades in
the making is at a critical stage and I
ask the develop the executive to support
the recommendations as set out thank
you thank you very much councilor Patel
for that comprehensive uh report on the
uh orings Carrington um uh Council
Williams you want to add
anything nothing to thank you Jo I think
um Council Patel been good job though at
at summarizing what is I appreciate it
Technical and quite Lely report thank
you thank you are there any other
questions or comments councilor
wght thank
you just switching itself on it's waking
up I use this one uh yeah just to just
to Echo what um councelor Williams has
said and Council Patel um as a war coun
um in Partington carington and South
West this has been um a long held
ambition um that we've had the the
people of Partington and Carrington want
this
infrastructure and we need the new
development and we need the new homes so
this is a very welcome step in the right
direction uh and I hope we can carry it
through and get it through the planning
process quick as quickly and and um as
successfully as possible thank
you thank you you and are there any
questions uh councilor
evence thank you chair um there's no
doubt I've got three questions there's
no doubt uh Communications for
Partington Carrington are very poor
there's no doubt something needs to be
done with the road that's in existence
um but just turning myself to this
specific report um we all know there
were doubts over the viability study
that was taken back in 20 2020 and it
was updated in 2021 the cost of G from
33 million to 76 million um and us as a
council are now going to commit what
looks to be in the table approximately
15 million to move forward which is only
20% of the likely funds available is it
not Cavalia to not revisit the viability
study um to actually know if it's ever
going to be viable and then bearing in
mind that gmca have been given 1 billion
we're likely to be asking for 5% of the
whole gmca a transport budget from
government for this single Road I think
there's some questions there um just
picking up on a one point because there
were so many points within councelor
Patel's presentation there um H how can
a temporary 106 agreement or S allow a
developer to budget properly I'm quite
worrying that we might say yeah today
it's this but it might change it if if
we're giving a developer a 106 agreement
they need a 106 agreement and then
finally which possibly could be picked
up with by uh councelor Ross we know the
hydrology for the temply wedge is
totally unknown and the flooding from
the temply wedge affects many parts of
South Trafford that flooding transfers
through where we're talking about now
here Carrington we don't know the hyd
hydrology from the uh Rivers Authority
what they call you know what they call
um we don't know the hydrology here and
it's a key outlet for water from traford
into the Mery and into the canal there's
a massive question mark there when do
you know Council Ross when the hydrology
reports are likely to be available for
well both but specifically this one
thank
you okay if I answer the the final one
first I would have to get that
information back to you but as I've said
in previous meetings from a GM
perspective we're working with the
environmental agency and United
utilities around the integrated Water
Management plan which does look at new
developments and um and the impact of
developments on the where water goes
potential flooding so I'd fully expect
that those reports and that methodology
will be there so we'll try and find that
out for you and get that information to
you but I'll pass over to council pel
for the other
two I think we are um the new viability
work is most welcome and we're the most
confident we've ever been about the
actual costs involved now I think
previous work
um didn't take into account our
Ambitions in terms of the breadth of the
highway for active travel Etc so that's
a lot of the cost has gone into that the
is 10 meter of the carriageway is
allocated to active travel now so the
actual design of it has moved forward
and that's fed into the
viability
um the growth zone so Carrington new
Carrington in a GM um capacity will be
one of GM's six growth zones
so to command a 5% budget of um um a
transport allocation which hasn't been
allocated yet but it will be a
significant amount because this is a
regionally significant project six
growth zones in great to Manchester and
new Carrington is one of them so it does
afford a GM level that that's
significant um I think the section of
the report I think it's section8 sort of
highlights a sort of a potted history of
106 contrib utions that we've secured um
pre in in the past I think the work that
we want to do through planning committee
and this report sets out actually
provides developers with some certainty
about
contributions um uh and we will do this
you know in discussion with um land
owners and our planning committee and I
think we'll get to a much better place
you know it's in the developers interest
to make a decent contribution because
currently the highway is at capacity so
you know if you if you're way in the
states just to use an example there are
many others and you want to see um your
housing development take off you know
there's a has to be a realistic
expectation around your contribution to
infrastructure in that regard um places
for everyone looked quite in in detail
at the flood risk assessment for this
area is not flooding I think that's the
issue here it's contamination and I
think that's set out in the report quite
clearly um uh the contaminants that
we're dealing with are a relatively new
new to to us as a local Authority and I
think to the industry so that's why it's
highlighted
there thank you councelor Patel
councelor
Welton thank you leader um I really uh
must uh applaud that the the report's
commitment to the 20-minute neighborhood
model in the you know in Carrington
itself um but what the report as a whole
really does illustrate is the shocking
car dependency that this development is
going to have and even the raft of me
measures outlined for scenario 2 barely
mov the dial with just a 5% reduction in
vehicle trips and um there's frequent
comparisons to an area of Bristol that I
know very well because I have an armed
there um Stoke gford Bradley Stoke
patchway and filton um and it's an area
of featureless Estates huge roundabouts
and massive link roads where people
yearn for a tram connection and you know
I think we have to fear that this is
going to be this could well be the fake
for for Carrington unless we try and
reach further for that um you know the
third scenario if possible
u i not note the issue of induced demand
is acknowledged um in section 1.1 of the
report leaving us in no doubt that the
building of Carrington will place more
pressure on the existing roads across
Trafford and that presumably that's why
numerous Junction improvements upgrades
are included particularly along the a56
which presumably is to cope with the
extra traffic um and that's obviously
going to have serious costs so I got a
few questions the first one is why is
there no analysis of the costs of not
achieving scenario 3 because not
achieving scenario 3 is going to cost us
more in terms of carbon emissions poorer
Public Health outcomes in terms of
exercise and obesity increased rates of
collisions costs of congestion and
higher costs of road maintenance no
where is that acknowledged in the report
surely these costs should at least be
considered against the cost of building
infrastructure when we're planning for
the very long term um uh secondly a much
more minor thing there's no mention of
demand responsive bus travel traffic
travel um which presumably should be you
know in a modernized bus system should
have a have a place um in there as well
as um you know enhanced regular bus
services which is of course welcome and
thirdly um as far as I'm aware um I'm
not an expert on this but Carrington
Greenway is still officially a live
train line even though there's no tracks
actually there um that many people would
like to see restored so what's the
likelihood of approval for its
conversion to a walking walking and
cycling route as is um indicated by the
plan thank you very
much okay thank you for your three
questions there um should I go to you
councilor Patel
first yeah um I think I'll need um aun's
advice on the scenario um three uh
question but I think it's a very open
and honest report um I don't think we're
trying to hide the fact that um you know
uh we aren't able to achieve the
ultimate sort of goal in sustainability
here but uh face with what we're we're
facing and and it's a realistic um and
ambitious project and I don't think it
rules out um possibilities that we can
improve on on the offer that we've got
here I think in time um you know this is
a project that will come out over over
decades new Carrington I think I think
we'll see great advances in um transport
and investment um in a country where hs2
goes off the rails and um I can't get
from to the city center very regularly
on a train I can't see us investing in
that in those uh Rail lines um but uh I
don't know about the demand um bus
modeling um that's a new point to me but
I think I think it's very much speaks to
um the B Network and the work around
that and how this is going to be based
on on bus transport in terms of public
transport um planning decisions are a
balance between um the economic the
social the environmental and I think
that this is a a fair and realistic
appraisal of where we are um I don't
know about Carrington Green Line being
alive rout um and whether we can walk
along it or not but I'm sure that that
is something we can um have a look at
could I ask aan to to point about the
cost of scenario
three yeah thank you Council Patel thank
you leader um yes Council Welton the um
well perhaps if I just deal with the
greenway point before we lose that um it
is you're quite right it is a live
Railway um it is owned by Network rail
although it is very heavily overgrown as
you may may be aware um it could uh
there are examples elsewhere though
where that is has been um converted to a
walking cycling route as perhaps a
precursor for um uh other approaches um
but obviously that's something we would
wish to develop in terms of scenario
three no doubt that is the most
sustainable option indeed that is uh as
we said in the report that's what we
would ideally like to move towards but
the the balance we strike really is is
uh trying to um model something that is
is is realistic within the resources
that are available and that's the Crux
of it is that you know we're having to
uh design infrastructure um for I
suppose the the funding World in which
we have it and and and therefore
scenario 2 is is is the best that is um
both sustainable but also reasonably
achievable within available and likely
to be available resources and that and
that's where the balance lies thank you
leader okay thank you uh councelor
Williams thanks chair just to note and I
think councelor battel touched on it we
are at the start of a journey in great
to Manchester towards uh gaining full
public control of our buses back and I
think that what Mr Bam's done around bus
franchising is exciting and I think we
we need to wait and see over the coming
months and years exactly what um new bus
services are going to look like and
certainly counc wel and if you want me
to take away that discussion about um I
to demand responsive for servicing it
I'm happy to do so great to Manchester
level and get that to
you great thank you um councelor
Enis thank you Council Ross I was
interested in councelor evans's question
just now about rivers and flooding um
the geography of Trappers waterways
hasn't changed since his party signed up
to places for everyone but I'm glad that
he's starting to catch on uh I want to I
do want to pick up a bit on the dishes
Railway at Carrington as well because
it's not previously been a popular
suggestion to try and bring it back into
use uh but active travel funding has
been allocated ated there as far as I'm
aware and I know that Partington Parish
Council have asked for a feasibility
study around potentially bringing that
back into use in more of an active
travel way does the exact support that
and and might that be something that be
able to be rolled into the report that
councilor Patel has just given when
might we see that feasibility to be
carried out surely just with the hs2
funds being diverted it would make sense
to be lobbying the government on that
rather than money being spent on roads
in North London we should be trying to
get some of that spent in the North
I I think it's best not to get me
involved in train chart would be here
all night so I'm going to go to
councilor Patel we can we can look into
that I can't um provide an immediate
response I I've got a memory of probably
about five or six years ago um uh via
Kate Green's office we lobbied uh we
tried to put together a case for
reopening Branch lines and and that was
one of them um and and it went nowhere
then and I don't think it will go
anywhere even with network North but um
we can take that one
away thank you and I think I had two
questions from the back so uh oh three
three okay well as your allward counsil
going to ask you to ask the question one
after the other and then we'll respond
so Council Holden you got the mic first
and then if councelor Duncan and
councelor Paul could uh line up behind
Council Holden and then asking questions
straight
after very question something
in the report there's a mention of new
primary schools and thousands of
houses only one mention Secondary
School which you know
about many of my residents are forced to
send their children to that school in
West because of the lack of space is any
consideration given to those
are going to their children
whens up with
children okay I'll ask councilor car
come in shortly but councelor Duncan did
you want to ask a
question yeah I thank you chair and
thank you EX
um as a manward counselor with
coun Council of PA and on behalf of the
residents I represent and indeed um
Beyond mward residents are feeling
frustrated and angry that the council
are neglecting their wishes and to
consider the environmental Devastation
so I've been asked to ask this question
to the executive so in relation to the
deat deposits on counter
moths the executive report States in
7.7 as a consequence Pete is not
considered to be a significant
constraint on future infrastructure
provision so this shows a huge lack of
understanding of the impact of drainage
on the main body of Pete which natural
in which natural in estimates to be
around 335 hectares traic Council seems
willingly to
disregard natural England's guidance and
feedback I was also at the same meeting
in December as Council hotel and there
were lots of worried residents
expressing concern thank
you thank you and finally final question
councelor
[Music]
Paul
thank you chair uh just like councel
Holden and councel dunan I'm speaking as
the Council of manward and on behalf of
my world residents I would like to state
that we are having deep concerns about
the whole development and I share their
concern this development is opposed by
most of the residents of mana and
understandably so the report talks about
investigations and ground reports about
the location of heat can this
investigation and Report be made for
open to public and wi thank you thank
you for your question so I will go to
councelor Carter first of all around
school places and then councelor Patel
about Pete hello thank you um councelor
Holden and The Perennial question about
high schools and S West um when we get
on to item 14 which is about the
expansion of school places you will see
one of the items that we requesting
approval for tonight is the expansion of
broad Oak so we're hoping
um it will go from 44 mry to 6 for mry
um and we are requesting to nearly 2
million pounds in um
106 um money to expand that school um if
if there is any issues with the 106
money we will fund it from basic need
because obviously as an area with a lot
of building going on it's been
identified that we need more school
faes
[Music]
that bus will still go past their houses
up to Broad o
absolutely and finding councelor
Patel um on the question of Pete I think
this report covers it um the the the
Pete question you're drawing into us
into a wider discussion on the um New
Carrington um allocation the public
examination dedicated two full days to
just the discussion of Pete it convene
two extra days and all the
documentation um and Survey results were
made public through that process I'm
afraid the um inference that this entire
area is full of deep Pete and it's um is
incorrect um and uh the uh discussion
about opposition to this piece of work
is is is in my opinion hyperball it
simply isn't reflected in the responses
we've received um to the places for
everyine consultation it isn't what I
hear on the doorstep what I hear is
people want New Roads new houses um and
and are quite happy for that to progress
so um a part of the master planning work
for new Carrington we are engaging with
land owners and struct Tre bodies to
undertake um a series of very detailed
um Environmental surveys on on the land
and the nature and extent of peak
deposits will be um even more um known
before any development takes place thank
you thank you councilor Patel so the
recommendations are 1 to four as set out
in the report all those in favor thank
you moving on to item seven which is the
overview and scrutiny review of the
executive's draft budget proposals for
245 councilor Dave Acton
thank you
leader um as you'll see in the report
scrutiny had held uh two scrutiny
meetings to consider the executive draft
budget and as a result of our scrutiny
um we we have set out eight
recommendations which I hope will be
helpful for the executive when
finalizing the budget
proposals I think um it was raised
several times around the the the funding
that we have um and uh I think in my
forward you
know it does highlight that Trafford
Council like many councils across the
country are finding it very difficult to
balance the budgets we're hearing every
day that that is a case and clearly this
situation is a result of 14 years of
austerity uh which has meant the council
has had a
reduction of nearly 300 million pound
taken out of its budget since that time
you know that is a a massive cut of
funding and it does have consequences
for services and that there's no doubt
about that uh it's putting a huge strain
um on the council's budget which in turn
means the council needs to continually
have to cut services to our residents
something none of us I think as
councilors and officers uh would want to
see therefore scrutiny members are very
supportive of the executive to continue
to Lobby government to provide improved
funding to Trafford and we are one of
the lowest funded councils in the
country so it it is a difficult time
that we we we we live in particularly
around the funding and providing the
services um but I think it would be
remiss of me U not to say that um I
would like to put on record my thanks to
the executive members and the corporate
leadership team and I would say all the
staff um the council staff for the work
that they carry out in these very
difficult times and similarly with with
the volunteers that we have and the
businesses that we have uh I think
everybody's working hard and together uh
to actually deal with these issues that
we have so thank you very
much thank you councilor Acton and by
extension the members of the committee
that helped put forward this uh report
it it's a very Stark report I think it
sets out the challenges that we face as
due other local authorities across the
country and I see that did get some
coverage um in the media last week as
well um we will take away the
suggestions and recommendations that you
have and we will report back at budget
itself which is only a couple of weeks
away we've just got a bit more
information to work through but I know
that officers executive members are
working as hard as we can to uh to get
to a balanced position for the February
budget so thank you for this and we will
come back to you in due course with our
response but appreciate scrutinous
efforts as
ever okay moving on we're going to go to
item eight which is the budget
monitoring report for period 8 which I
will take in uh Council Harding's
absence so um despite the challenging
Financial environment that I've just
referred to and it was put in the uh the
scrutiny report um it is encouraging to
see that our position has moved from a
projected overspend at period six of
half a million pounds to a projected
underspend of half a million pounds at
period eight or I should say
0.59 uh million pounds at period 8 much
of this is because of the effectiveness
of our financial management practices
and additional in-year controls that
were put in place as it looked like um
the overspend was being projected the
report sets out the variances from
budget under each directorate and gives
an update on the capital program as set
out in section six and Annex 3 gra I
don't know if there's anything you'd
like to uh highlight as
well yeah just just to reiterate what
the leader said I think in terms
of the movement in that position from
period
six um it has been positive and I think
from my point of view it's just would
always targeted to leave that
position like that such that we weren't
calling on reserves to any
more um of a demand than what we'd
already included in the budget so we're
really conscious don't want to overspend
which would lead to an unplaned use of
Reserve so in that sense the report's
really positive I
think obviously the leaders just
mentioned about setting the budget for
245 and as we've developed this this
budget model monitoring position for
234 we have used that to inform that
position particularly in some of the
demand Le areas that are causing budget
pressure and but we've reflected those
in the 245 budget
planning um I think just another couple
of things around contingencies the
position at period 8 this still the
third of the year to report on um and
there is about a million pound of
contingency pockets and I say that in in
the sense of we've got a small
contingency left in children Services
some in adults and we've also got a
corporate small balance on the corporate
contingency still left so
um positive at this point but still a
little way to go
yet thank you greme I'll take your
positive at this point it's probably the
most optimistic thing I've heard from
you for a very long time so thank you
and thank you to all your colleagues and
yourself for for all the uh the work
that you do around uh supporting our
finances are there any other comments or
questions from the executive
any further questions I'll go to council
Evans first thank you chair got six
comments um try and do them in order
although the last one won't be in order
page 223 business rates 2.2 million
deficit I presume that's with respect to
well it is refurbishment work at traffic
center that's is that now over that
won't be in next year so effectively we
get 2.2 million back that's suppose just
be yes or no really bear with me a
second page
um around the market I don't understand
how have we ended up with a
63,000 rent reduction for the market
when of all areas in altering I know we
got problems at the end of graph you
know there's a lot of empty space at the
end
of the graftons ETC but the market is is
reported to be booming how do we end up
with uh a reduction there and then the
building control um the loss on the
building control surely we got planning
applications how do we how does that
actually happen if that if you could
inform us on
that uh 244 is more a comment I think
the language around treasury management
um in yet and reduce the council's under
borrowed position which was 93
million it makes out and I I do worry
about the language the language there
makes out that the underbar position is
a problem whereas actually it's a bonus
to be under because you don't have to
pay the uh the interest so I I would ask
if maybe we could revisit uh the
language
please um page 252 excuse the potential
ignorance here I thought
H gmca were paying for electric vehicle
charging points uh not all and if we are
can we not um get beev because they'll
be in due course making money out of
them I think the urgency around electric
vehicle charging points is somewhat
reduced since we got the amendment
several years ago to get them
installed and you'll be pleased to
know again language uh
264 um that paragraph on 264 the
forecast for 2023 is negative due to the
inflow of interest payments to the
council I.E investment income being
higher than the gross f it does not make
sense to an outside reader and I really
struggle with that I know what that
means because I S on the investment
management board that could be a lot
clearer to the outside world and one
final thing which is a I applaud really
which is Page 227 the removal of the
scheme for the installation of two
ration cremators I'm absolutely stunned
that 2 million was in the budget
originally I can't believe that we
didn't pick up on this two or three
years ago that the resummation creators
the boiling the bag of the body and
flushing it into the drains it does it's
not not a thing it it's so experimental
how did we it's not really a question
I'm stunned we ever committed 2 million
pound to an experimental process thank
you about three questions
there okay the two points on language
absolutely we can take that away and um
you're right the more that we can do to
demystify um these reports the better
all around um in terms of resume that
was one of my favorites a few years ago
I mentioned it twice in budget speeches
going by um I think we looked at it from
a um environmental um point of view um
it's better for the environment I know
what you say about flushing and we don't
want to go into too much detail here but
from an environmental point of view it
was it was better than the traditional
cremation approach but looking at the
water courses and everything El it
turned out we couldn't do it so that's
why we rode back from there um if I go
to gra around the business rates point
and it might be that Adrian you take the
market rent potentially on the buildings
control area so gram
first the business rate issue obviously
the challenge we've had this year about
maintaining income levels it's just a
timing issue so we're now projecting the
income big unit was the M dispensers
unit so that income's now operating
we're waiting for the vaa the valuation
office agency to put the unit back onto
the rating list such that we can start
getting that income but it will be PID
from when they opened so it's purely
timing so and we've accommodated that in
budget planning for
245 okay and
Adrian uh yes so as as regards building
Control building control effectively
operates as as a business and the
figures that you're seeing here um
reflect a period where um we have a very
short on staff initially and so lost um
uh lost business because we didn't have
the fee earners in place um and and um
uh and it will also reflect the fact
that having had no reduced staff when we
bring the team back to uh Fuller
strength um there's a time lag between
the fee earnings that those new staff uh
bring in but of course we're still
paying for them so uh it is hopefully
something that will work through the
system but but I think the key thing is
that um building control effectively is
is a traded Service uh and and so is
subject to variations over time in
relation to the amount of market share
we can earn and the costs that we incur
through primarily through Staffing um as
regards the the the market um if I may
Le to come back to on that point I
wouldn't want to I think I know the
answer but better get it right thank
you thank you and in terms of EV
charging we're we're as we say we're
looking to expand the number of EV
charging so any Revenue that we can
recoup from that we're very very keen to
as a Council for obvious reasons so um I
know councilor Williams and myself work
closely in terms of looking at expanding
opportunities there and we'll continue
to do so so okay uh councelor Enis thank
you chair um we desperately need proper
funding reform don't we and um we've had
some crumbs from Michael Go's table last
week um just getting over how
disrespectful it is to finance offices
to make announcements in that manner
less than a month before we're expected
to set our budget are you able to say at
the stage how how that money will impact
Trafford what we'll get whether it's
based on the old outdated funding model
and whether that'll be able to save off
any potential cuts to particularly in
Social
Care thank you yeah and and this is one
of the reasons why we may have to delay
the publication of our papers because um
we we're still going through the
information that's been announced last
week I don't know if there's been any
Clarity since uh the end of last week
but we were supposed to be briefed about
the actual figures at the budget in it
was was was so we're going to have to
put some caveats in the papers that we
put together in terms of the final
figures um we are still working as an
executive with the corporate leadership
team around that um we've got uh a a
session after this to look at um some of
the figures and the impacts of of this
so we'll be we'll be running late into
the night tonight as we uh as we look to
balance the budget it looks like it's
going to help a little bit but if I tell
you that the draft we about 6.2 million
at draft that we had to bridge after the
Autumn statement and the settlement at
this the end of the year that widened to
about 7even 7.4 million pounds so we're
looking to have closed that Gap a little
bit but there's still a number of things
that we're going to have to do to
produce the balanced budget this year so
it would be good and I know that local
government as a as as as a public
service is um has got a good reputation
on the whole for for spending money
while wisely so I think the really sad
thing is you look through our budget
monitoring report you see all the
services we're we're running you see the
way that we manage our budgets we could
do so much more for the residents of
this burough if we were properly funded
which is why we'll continue to um
Champion the Farah funding cores because
Trafford has got a structural issue when
it comes to finances we are one of the
lowest funded per head out of all local
authorities and unless that changes
we're going to have more and more
difficult budget rounds coming up
because the um this peace meal approach
that we're getting from government is is
unsustainable you see the other councils
it's really impacting on we're doing our
very best here with this Council and you
can see that through the work we've done
during this year as we've uh we've got
to a underspend of half a million but
it's hard it's really
hard any other questions uh councilor
but thank you CH mine's around table
[Music]
one it's just really uh looking at the
increased cost around legal
governance finance and systems and Men
other
those okay I might pass
to Emma do you think you could do legal
and government governance for
me
I can uh briefly and then I'll come back
to if there's any further detail that
you'd find helpful um councel about what
I can say is this is something uh that
has been discussed within the Forum of
the employment committee um the legal
and governance service have been
carrying a number of significant number
of vacancies uh over a number of years
which has resulted in an increase in
agency spend uh that's something we are
seeking to address um we have just
just excuse me implemented um a service
redesign which was implemented on the
1st of January and we hope to be able to
recruit uh to our vacant permanent posts
uh to reduce the pressures on agency
spend okay and in terms of finance and
systems it's Trafford assist that looks
like it's the uh the big pressure there
so it's uh 200,000 pound um which is due
to continuing additional uptake in
demand so I think it really reflects the
cost of living crisis and people
approaching the council for help and and
and clearly we we are going to do our
best to assist people at times of need
and that's why there's an overspend in
that budget area um Council
Welton thank you very much um just
looking at the uh cost of the delayed
opening of the Regent Road car park um
still seems to be going on there seem
still seems to be a big Divergence
between the where the developer is at
and where the council thinks the car
park is at does there come I mean I hate
to say it does there come a point where
it becomes actually more cost effective
for the council to get involved in
actually finishing the darn place off um
or um or what else can be done to to get
the developer to to to do the job that
they were supposed to do finish it and
get it open
safely it's a very good question and a
very good point and clearly the top is
safety and making sure we have a safe
structure and um I'm going to pass over
to Adrian to see if he wishes to oh
sorry councilor Patel
first I mean we aren't at that point
where it's more coste effective for us
to take over and finish the work um we
um Council officers um did an inspection
of the car park in January um around 180
um snacks and defects some of them uh
relating to um the safety and the
structure of the building which um take
it into a considerable amount of work um
we're exploring all avenues possible to
get the developer to comply and complete
the work and hand it over as promised as
soon as
possible okay thank you uh and one more
from councel Evans thank you chair just
picking up on councel welton's point it
look I'm not sure what the exactly what
the figures are it looks like it could
be 90 grand a month or something of that
order is there any angle for pursuing
the developer for our loss
um because if this goes on much longer
it's it was supposed to be October as we
all know if it's if it's next summer
it's a lot of money thank you Council
Patel you want to I don't know the
extent of the the sort of the legal um
Powers we have but we are um as I said
investigating all opportunities to get
it handed over as soon as possible um
it's costing us money um and um we were
promised a completed um car park some
months ago um and we're we we're running
out of um PTI Pati to be quite honest
thank
you it is a huge frustration what's
happening there and thank you for
raising okay so with this item it's
recommendations a to c as set out in the
report all those in agreement thank you
we'll go to agenda item nine which again
I am taking on behalf of councelor Joan
Harding so this is the business rates
relief autum business measures and
National nonis Domestic rating
discretionary policy changes
20242 um the report seeks approval of
the extension to the 75% retail
hospitality and Leisure business rates
relief scheme in 2425 in line with
government guidance and funded through a
section 31 Grant it also seeks approval
for amendments to the council's National
non-domestic rating discretionary policy
to include some backdating Provisions
that currently exist in legislation I
don't know if anyone has any questions
or comments from the executive on
this any further
questions okay well the recommendations
are one and two in the report all those
in favor thank you uh qu item number 10
which again I'll take in councilor
hing's absence uh council tax report
support scheme
20242 can I direct colleagues back to
the November meeting where the council
tax support scheme came up in great
detail there
um reference back to that report uh this
is seeking approval for the scheme as
set out in the wording of the November
report there so any questions or
comments from executive
members any further questions or
comments councelor
Evans soor I hope my notes are in the
right place is this this is oh they're
not is this the M homes pages so I'm
ahead of
myself okay uh no other question
okay the uh recommendation is as set out
all those in favor and then getting on
to councilor evans's item uh council tax
empty homes and second homes premium
introduction and proposal to consult on
exempt categories which I will take in
Council Harding's absence um the
leveling up and regeneration Act of 2023
as it should say in section two not 2003
in the title enables Council to apply
100% premium on empty properties after
one year at present it's after two years
we are seeking to do this from the 1st
of April 2024 and from the 1st of April
2025 the council can charge a
discretionary council tax premium of
100% on second homes of which there are
797 in the burough the exemptions are
listed on 3.4 section 3.4 and we are
seeking approval to consult any
questions or comments from the
executive councelor Evans simple one
what happens to airbnbs because there
are quite a few with Manchester United
and the
cricket it's a good question uh
Graham if the categorize as second homes
they be liable to a premium but as the
leader said that the second homes
premium will be effective from April 25
and that's a
legislation thank you and Council buts
thank you uh I just want to ask about
the cons
and what form will that take
and that sometimes
consultation thank you gra I don't know
if you've got any information on the
form the consultation will
take not specifically other than we do
say it's public consultation we normally
undertake that for a month although I a
bit longer but if that's something I can
get back to with specific details BR
thank you gra thank you councelor but
councelor Enis just small technical
Point really on the exemptions um
because I appreciate the council's kept
pace with with legislation's change
since I think Trafford first looked at
the scheme in maybe 2019 it was I looked
at an earlier version of this policy and
I think there may be an exemption
missing around the arm Services Covenant
and just if that could be looked at
again it may be that that's changed but
I think in an earlier iteration of this
policy we did have something in for
service
Personnel thank you know you're
absolutely right to raise that and we'll
take that away and have a look at that
thank you for raising that
Council thank you I I will um vly
support this as it's something our world
colleague campaign on back in 20
2019 um just I'm looking again at the
exemptions new owners of empty
properties undergoing major
repairs um the safeguards that are in
place so someone doesn't become exempt
just because they've registered to vote
in a property and stuck up some
scaffolding and then scarp it off to
another country for six
months is there going to be that kind of
safeguarding in there because I mean I'm
knocking on doors and I know one person
registered there's no one living in that
house uh and there's building work that
looks like it is a happening but isn't
moving
forward thank you for that again that's
a very good point I think we can take
that away but also I'd encourage you to
when we do set out the consultation to
get anything like that any suggestions
and you know contributions into the
consultation then we'll come back with
the uh with the final policy but thank
you everyone that's that's really
helpful okay so um we are seeking
approval to consult those in favor
brilliant thank you now I have
remembered councelor Thompson I am now
going to change the agenda and we are
going to go to item number 13 first
which is the Trafford Community
Collective update over to you thank you
chair and this is quite a comprehensive
reports around the work of the collected
over the last two years the collective
became a registered charity in 2021 with
support from voluntary sector the
council and traffic ccg as it was known
then as such it has become one of our
strategic partners and helps to deliver
our priorities especially around Health
inequalities and supporting people out
of poverty the report gives the history
of the collectives development from 2019
to present day where it now works across
our community hubs and is a growing
membership of voluntary sector groups
and as such is becoming a key strategic
voice of the sector in March last year
Trafford Council and NHS Trafford
committed a
130,000 to continue its work into
2025 this report out outlines the
meetings the collective facilitates
between the lead partners and also the
support the voluntary sector
representatives to sit on several boards
and they also operate three reference
groups made up of 15 to 20 different
organizations who in inform our services
such as children's services and our
Mental Health Services the collective
supported the recent successful funding
bid of six new voluntary coordinated
posts in our hubs they they are
currently awaiting the outcome of a
joint bid with Manchester University of
a 1 million point 1.3 million pounds to
develop locally based initiatives to
reduce Health inequalities in our
diverse communities and there's more
details in that in of in the report the
collective has also been working with
our health and Primary Care Network to
find new ways of tackling health inqu
qualities in our poor areas our sale
West Hub was chosen as one of the
greatest Manchester five pilot
schemes under the test and learn Banner
where local DPS and nurses access
residents using our community hubs and
this has been been deemed as a success
and is due to be rolled out across our
po neighborhoods this year the
collective working with the council has
also grown its specialist staff team to
work in the volunteer sector such as a
violence reduction worker a mental
health lead a Skool streets worker and
an aging in place worker the collective
is becoming a large and effective
Network and promotes information to the
sector around funding opportunities
volunteering events campaigns and job
opportunities they also support the
delivery of the Vol of the Trafford V
vcss
strategy I want to take this opportunity
to thank George deling for developing
the collective over the years and his
true dedication to the sector he's
standing down this spring and we look
forward to working with the new chief
officer when they take up their position
so thank
you thank you councelor Thompson can I
also add my thanks to George develin as
well who has worked wonders with the
community Collective amongst with all
all the other people involved um you
having looked at the presentation that
was part of the the agenda it just shows
how high you punch above the weight of
the organization itself and the amount
of uh support and benefit you brought to
the burough and of course supporting our
voluntary Community sector as well which
we should be very proud of as a b as
well we have such a rich and diverse
voluntary in community sector so thank
you very much George and thank you to
everyone at the community Collective for
you everything you've done um to support
us here in traford any questions or
comments from executive members members
oh yes so councelor Slater first of all
thank you for the thank you lader and
thanks for this report um it's really
really informative and I think that the
work that the community Collective do
for do alongside Trafford is just
outstanding and the work that they
supported us with during covid to reach
those hard to reach communities it was
second to n so you know I welcome the
report thanks for all the hard work
thanks again to George because he has
been an absolute star getting this off
the you know getting this from his tiny
group to growing the way it has and some
of the stuff that they do for us around
our Adult Services I don't know they do
around Children's Services but you know
for me from our Adult Services it's
excellent work and I just thanks thanks
for the report and I just want to
congratulate um the the collective on
what they deliver for us Trafford
thanks thank you and councelor Williams
thanks chair and thank you Ben councelor
Thomson for speaking to the report I
just wanted to know really how welcome I
think it is that that funding was put in
place to for an additional School
streets officer um I know that you were
recently with councilor Slater Victoria
Park in Stratford as they rolled out
their School Street and I think these
schemes are proving popular with
residents and families locally um I
think it's really welcome that the bcfs
sector is going to shown an interest in
playing a role in supporting our school
streets as more and more schools come
forward to have a scheme implemented
thank you chair thank you and as it
happens I spent the morning with the
school streets officer but we were on
bikes this time um but she was telling
me about how successful the school
Street of SE Park in Old Trafford had
been and the really good feedback that
uh it's received from everywhere so
hopefully we can secure funding and keep
going with that Venture because it is um
it is proving popular on the whole um
are there any questions
from why oh Council Patel first and then
I'll go to councilor po just welcome the
report is very informative in a time of
such limited resources and growing need
you know this sort of work really really
is uh need needed just to comment on the
um working partnership with primary care
I know that in salmore we were one of
the successful areas to um be to operate
a test and learn
um I don't often but I sometimes
volunteer at the food bank there and
when I've seen that test and learn um
project in place um you know the nursing
staff there um get through to three or
four residents who otherwise would have
never have called into a GP and um
detect all sorts of um issues and and
direct them to to help which they
wouldn't um necessarily have found
anyway so a really worthwhile um cause
um thank
you thank you um Council lorei thank you
chair and I um want to Echo councilor
Slater and everyone else's comments
about how welcome this report is and how
good this Collective has been for so
many people in Trafford
[Music]
and obviously say I uh are involved with
um I'm involved even with um the South
neighborhood and with broomwood moves um
my only
concern uh moving forward was
about focusing in as we rightly should
on those areas of deprivation and of
where people are are really struggling
but as we move forward I don't want to
see a lag um with people that have
obviously suffered financially over the
past few years and are now struggling
but don't look like they're struggling
so they don't get left out and left
behind just because they live in a
postcode that is appears to be aent and
I've mentioned that to our uh South
neighborhood lead um and yeah I just
want them to keep up the great work I
think it's great thank you thank you uh
councelor Thompson do you want to
respond to that St is a concern I
believe last year over three qus of a
million people used food banks that
never used food banks before in their
lives so is a concern and obviously we
we tailor tailor the services around
that
awareness and finally Council Welton
yeah I had the pleasure of attending our
South neighborhood meeting with Council
Lori um towards the end of last year I
was very impressed by the number of
people there but also the caliber of the
people there and I think it was really
encouraging seeing all the connections
that were being made between um between
different
organizations um both you know in in the
care sector and in the voluntary sector
um so that's encouraging I think is
there another one this week is it next
week some coming soon coming soon anyway
and looking forward to that thank you
it's a really good initiative and also
really good to hear that we are looking
to extend the funding for the school
streets officer um because I think you
know it's it's a great start that's been
made and it would be such a shame to
lose that now so that's positive I think
we we're seeking any funding streams we
can to extend it so um clearly going
back to our financial situation it's not
not something that we'll be able to do
in isolation but um I know that we had
the opportunity with Dame Sarah story
and of Trad support for gra Manchester
this morning to talk about the success
of the school Street scheme so yeah we
are exploring Avenue so that we can keep
it going and it's definitely something
that we as an Administration wish to
wish to do okay so the report rep is for
noting and approving further progress
report so those in favor thank you and
on behalf of the executive can we thank
George delin for all his time with the
community Collective and we wish him
well with any future endeavors he has
okay moving on to um item 12 now which
is the rights to the streets update and
back to council Rose Thompson thank you
CH try and keep this brief um with the
notes of the time that we've got left uh
this report provides an end of projects
overview of the rights to the street
project in North traford the rights of
the street project was a home office
funded gender-based violence Street
Safety project it commenced in Trafford
in September 22 and completed a year
later this project combines Community
activity policy work podcasting visual
campaigns social media artwork and
Community grants to build a wide
reaching impactful Grassroots project
the project focused on North Trafford in
garil Old Trafford and stford Aries and
was shaped through an ongoing co-design
process using local data engagement
events and art projects and there's far
more detail on the GM moving. co.uk
website where a full report has just
been published on there it was delivered
in Partnership consisting of a variety
of key organizations that took
responsibility for certain areas of the
project and there's a list of Partners
in your in your um reports and the
respective areas that their work covered
and it shows the whole system approach
to the the
project um traffic Council maximize the
impact to local residents through
helping connect the project with local
activity and partners as well as
informing wider policy and planning
and Trafford the collective uh traffic
Community Collective Community connect
worker where organized the community
grants in Old Trafford and the north of
the borus uh scheme and she did a really
good job and I want to thank Verity for
organizing that as a strategic partner
traffic Council supported rights the
streets through building networks Making
Connections our Ro has been supporting
the project with expertise networking
and focusing on local area the legacy of
the project has been varied and this
includes the opportunity of rights to
the streets Council has secured
£20,000 funding from The Cooperative
council's Innovation Network to deliver
a policy lab on tackling violence
against women and girls working with
eight other councils across the UK the
evidence and knowledge from the project
will be used to share approaches from
councils across the UK and this work
will continue into
2024 and will be evaluated in this
summer I believe as part of the
legislative theater commitments the EXA
members and policy team continue to
engage with great man Manchester
contacts to be involved in key work in
the area going forward and traffic
Council will be working with the gmca on
their new uh uh
uh violence against girls and women
strategy delivery plan in
2024 and I just want to highlight how
this has informed our work the rights of
the street has helped with traffic
council's thinking When developing our
more mov partnership in traffic moving
priority areas this is through
understanding of localities and the
issues with them this has been
particularly seen across in part parts
inton and the leveling up fund project
at Partington Sports Village and
crosslane parks and where traffic
Council ensure that women and girls
safety from male violence was considered
throughout the elements of the
project so it's so I'm yes so it's um
there's more information on G GM moving.
co.uk website is a full evaluation of
what happened in traford and Beyond so
thank you thank you councelor Thompson I
think it's a excellent uh project that
took place very near to where I live and
I know a lot of people in the area
really benefited and appreciated it um
any questions or comments Council Slater
again thank you for this report I think
the work that's been done around balance
against women and girls has been really
really good really prominent and I think
that we we shouldn't forget that should
be in everything that we look at on a
daily basis when we're planning when
we're looking at opening up cycle ways
on issues Railways we need to be
thinking about violence against women
and girls as as the first thing when
we're looking at when we're creating um
spaces across Trafford and I just wanted
to say that that bystander training that
was excellent and I think that that you
know that's something that we should
update on a regular basis because when
people stand by and allow things to
happen to women and girls and haven't
spoken up then we just need to be making
sure that we all we're all we're not by
standards we actually get involved and
we support women and girls around that
so thanks again for an excellent report
Rose thank you
thank you any other questions or
comments okay any questions from uh
councilor
leori it's just a a further comment
chair about can we try and get something
very similar uh in Ultram area I know
there's been some reports recently of
problematic behavior and in case of
women and girls as well some
victimization in the area it's becoming
it's still a night spot area and
least struggling to cope down there with
some of the problems that they're
dealing with thank
you thank you we can certainly take that
away and uh and look at that and how we
work with Partners around that so thank
you okay oh Council Welton thank you
yeah I will um back Council pory up this
does come up on the doorstep um quite a
bit um as we as we knock on doors um and
actually you i' spoken to some residents
who've raised the issue about this
project and they really interested in it
um obviously it's very been very
geographically focused but um but I
think there is potential for for for um
maybe a crossb project if if if some
kind of funding could be um could be
found for something similar and
absolutely agree that we you know we
really need to focus funding on on on
lit routs um and you know it Greenways
are are lovely but actually roads with
safe C cycling infrastructure that are
lit should be absolutely be the first
priority of the council I totally
agree okay thank you so we we can take
away and explore this model that clearly
worked in in the gell area if it's
something funding permitted we could
explore in other parts of Trafford it is
important across traford that we we
tackle violence against women and girls
and and make traford as safe as it can
be so I know C Thompson is passionate
about that as well and uh we can take
that away so this is for no noting we'll
consider it noted thank you very much
for presenting that there councelor
Thompson if we move on to item 14 the
education and early needs capital and
over to councelor Karina Carter thank
you leader um this report details the
proposals to address the shortfall of
school places and also how traffic
Council are meeting the needs of
children and young people with
scnd I think we all know that Trafford
is a popular Authority due to its ex
excellent Ed UC ational provision and
the report shows how traffi is actually
regarded as an Exemplar by the DF for
managing provision of school places so
since
2010 an additional
4,646 places have been
created and the report details of the
rise in applications in both primary and
high schools and the reasons for that
and how schools have been expanded to
make meet the unprecedented demand for
places the report also mentions about
the efforts of officers local
counsellors and the two MPS for the
altering and sale area to secure a new
school in the sale altering area um but
this was rejected by the
DFE section four discusses the three
Early Education places a much trumpeted
government
initiative um alow the the Prime
Minister did say last week it's be set
with practical
issues um and one of the main issues in
Trafford is that we're not sure we're
going to have um the right number of
staff to be able to provide the free CH
child care that's being offered so we're
currently undergoing a sufficiency
exercise to see whether we can make it
work obviously we need the government to
announce more sort of funding details
about this scheme as
well section five details to demand for
school places for children with send and
how we are increasing the amount of
places at local schools which is part of
our strategic initiative and um we've
developed SSC small specialist classes
within mainstream schools to keep as
many children um with complex needs in
the burough as
possible so the report is asking for
recommendations the proposals are um we
want to proceed with the expansion of
alrin college which will secure us
another 300
places we are looking at the feasibility
of expanding North destrian by buying
the Loretto prep site um and this is
being investigated at the
moment as previously mentioned we want
to expand broad Oak School and we're
also expanding Brentwood
School so happy to take questions would
like to thank the officers the um
Capital team in education Sarah Butters
Karen samples and Joel
mcgreger thank you thank you uh
councelor Carter I think given the
amount of regeneration work happening in
traff this is a very common question as
Council Holden asked earlier on in the
meeting is well what happens with school
place so this this item demonstrates how
the council plans um for for school
places as as when demographics change
numbers of uh properties change so it's
a really important item that we look at
on a regular basis are there any
questions or comments from the executive
councilor
Patel uh thank you I would just like to
um Echo um councelor Carter's thanks to
officers and the uh DFE recognition for
our good approach to school allocation
is worth noting um faced with uh you
know significant demand and need changes
we respond calmly and comprehensive ly
to that um despite it often trying to be
used as a political football we've just
steered at a calm course through it
thank you um as a governor of templemore
infant school I would like to thank the
capital team from one Trafford and the
council for um uh a smooth management of
the expansion of that school um it was
done um you know on time within budget
and um to a good standard thank you
thank you Council Patel that's very good
to hear um okay councilor Enis first of
all thank you chair
um thank you chair um picking up on the
point about uh regeneration works and
increased demand if there's a need for a
new school as part of the potential
future traffic Waters development why is
what I'm interested in the department of
education's reason for rejecting a
school in in South Trafford what are the
reasons that that sit behind that um if
if MPS have lobbied and even so gra
Brady couldn't change his own
government's mind you know surely we
should be able to talk about what the
reasons are behind uh that rejection and
and on send as well where a child I want
to ask specifically where a child is
without a send place and and out of
Education how often should traffic
Council be touching base with that
family okay I'll start with why we can't
have a new school
um you so you're not allowed to have a
single form entry so the the the
government set a certain um size of
school which I think 750 pupils
we currently haven't got
750 families without a place at the
moment it's averaging about 90 in the
sale in altringham so they do say and if
you're sat in London I get this you've
got enough spaces in Trafford because we
have got spaces in lostock and we've got
spaces in Broad and we've got spaces in
Wella so on paper it looks like we have
enough provision in the burough
obviously those schools aren't where the
parents who who are lacking a place want
to send the children to school but I
think you're absolutely right we we've
been all around the houses and once you
include c um Mike Kan and P and S gr and
Brady and they just come back and say no
um because you've got enough places so
that's the reason we can't have a new
school up there but all of the high
schools up there on on really quite
tight sites it's really difficult to be
able to expand so we looked at North
CEST originally and said no we haven't
got enough room which is why we've gone
for alron college but Wellington of you
know Wellington on a tight site Ash Mery
tight site you know so it's really
difficult to expand existing
schools can I come back there just
really quickly chair um given the
Redevelopment work that is proposed by
this Administration for timly wedge how
sufficient do you think the expansion of
alterum college will be is it enough
given 2,000 odomes yeah well we can only
we can you know there's a formula for
when new houses are built for how many
school places going to need so we can
only go off what we know um so it's
another 300 places altering college and
also s High are having two blocks
rebuilt so part of the problem with um
School places is it's not an exact
science so what we couldn't have done
was predict the amount of people who
would have moved into the burough
through the Hong Kong scheme through
ukrainians and people who quite frankly
are picking to move here in years four
and five so their children get a chance
at going for the grammar schools so
we're unusual in that respect that we do
get more more um influx at that stage
but actually the birth rate is falling
massively so we can expand all of those
secondary schools and then we'll be left
with empty places 10 years down the line
so that's the that's the um you know the
Dilemma that the capital team have to
work with but I agree I think if we had
more spaces over there we would fill
them that you know it won't be a problem
but um you know it it's just trying to
balance what's right with what
financials we've got as well so I don't
know if Jill wants to add to
that if you can have a look at um
sections three in the report that I
think outlines what the roots are for
building new schools and I think as
Council councilor Carter has already
articulated it's a complex formula in
terms of taking into account birth rates
in year migration and actually what the
demand would be in terms of um
predicting future level of demand there
are only two routes in terms of which we
would be in a position to build
um secondary schools and I think it's
fair to say that officers um met
regularly including myself with dfy to
articulate the case and the pressures
and the outcome was that as Council
Carter has already said that's actually
the Gap in terms of what the demand was
in specific areas in the buau was not
sufficient to Warrant the building of a
whole
school and the question on send as well
yeah can you just repe please yeah so
where a child is without Ascend place
and out of Education how often should
traffic Council be touching base with
the
family I'm slightly um curious about
without a place because actually we work
very hard in terms of meeting our
sufficiency needs for children who do
have um send needs and we do locate we
do make placements outside of of the bah
in terms of seeing children who have um
send
needs we are limited by consent of
parents in terms of what we can do in
terms of knocking on doors I think in
terms of our ability to meet placements
I would suggest the overspend that I've
got on some of my high needs would
suggest that we are working very hard to
make sure that we meet parental requests
meet the need in terms of children with
send regardless whether it's in b or
outside of
Bah councelor Anis if you got some
specific case workk send it
through it's not specific but I am happy
to take it up outside of the meeting CH
thank you okay thank you we'll move on
to councelor Evans now thank you thank
you chair um section
2.6 um the the rag rating basically um I
do I'd like to see that expanded really
to be fair in that um to say stretford
um is green and green I imagine
stretford high is full I imagine
stretford grammar is full I imagine
that's one school there where you've got
some capacity we understand where
Partington at we' touched on it every
other area is red or Amber um I would
like to see that expanded next time
around so we can actually see where
these places are because I think it's a
little disingenuous because it removes
choice and it will be you will go to
this school irrespective of what your
attainment is good bad or actually your
need is um I think that's quite worrying
to be fair um I think we have got that
detail actually I've seen that detail
before but I I think we need to be
realistic counselor that parental
choice is more of a myth nowadays and
actually well we say parents have a
choice but you don't really if I'm
honest depending on where you live you
know um as as Council holdon well knows
you know that schools used to have
catchment areas which they still have in
name but that you know the catchment
areas have got so small for some of our
schools less than a mile that you know
you might want your child to go to
Wellington but unless you live really
really close to that school you wouldn't
really have a choice so people bandi the
phrase around parental Choice it's
really limited really
limited if I can just come in councelor
Evans in relation to that table that
table relates to the primary overview
and if you look at um paragraph 2.2 94%
of all Trafford residents um were
allocated their first preference in
terms of school and 99% were allocated
one of their first two or three um
preferences so I would suggest that that
shows there is a good level of
compliance in The primary sector with
parental choice to be fair my error I
was referring to the next table so I
apologize for that that's me just
referring to wrong area but My worry is
um not for I am worried for the children
in Out My worry is for that the the the
deprived child in Partington who because
of where we are is never going to see an
opportunity to go to to have any choice
about where that child goes and that
applies to Partington it applies to
stretford I myself came from erston and
ended up at stretford grammar when it
was stretford high or is now stretford
High then it was full we were taught in
Porter cabins we've had pter cabins
craned into the quad there these schools
are busting at the seams um I will
attempt I will speak to rmp I will go
back to the BF we do need a
school please do I mean we we've also
involved him well your man Mr Carol um
has involved him in um um the the um
Loretto prep project and we've had a
letter back from Baron as Baron saying
that there is no funding for for us to
be able to expand North sestrin which we
believe is much needed and would be very
valuable for that area um you know and
you think well actually if srum can't
get it done we haven't got any hope at
the
moment okay thank you I'm going to move
on now so councelor but and then final
question councelor
Welton good few years knocking on
the so
that's we we did we talked about this
last week didn't we Council but it's a
complex project sport England um are not
being as helpful as we think they could
be but you know we will deliver another
300 places but it's now being put back
to
2026 I know I've got some ideas in of
being increase the or improve the the
logistics on clear places more traffic
but there is capacity within the area to
be able to di some
traffic okay if you want to send them by
email we can get them to the right
people
thank you and finally councelor Welton
yeah I have a lot of sympathy for
officers working on this because you
need some kind of Mystic me type powers
to get it absolutely right with with
Rising birth rates and then falling
birth rates and then a whole bunch of
schools that have got really unhelpful
selection policies that could be tweaked
slightly to to fit those 90 extra
children in in the local schools in the
south of the in the in the south of the
burough but they don't so we have we're
importing children from everywhere
everywhere else and we're exporting
children to schools that parents don't
really want to send their children to
because they're very far away and only
last only last week I was I had a um I
was rung by a parent whose child had
been had been um involved in an Al
altercation on the bus going being being
D you know being driven all the way
across Trafford and we and um and
unfortunately you know that's put them
off that you
know having to their child having to go
all that way and it's incredibly
difficult um
but I do want to say thank you very much
to the chief executive for for who
joined us on a visit to North krian a
couple of weeks ago just to see I know
it's really interesting to see the the
proximity of North krian to um to
Loretto prep and and I think in terms of
the you know the birth rate is actually
quite symbolic given that we've got
falling roles at at primary and here is
an empty primary school and I fear that
in a few years time we're going to have
more empty primary schools and primary
schools are actually going be closing um
potentially um but the potential for it
for for it probably be to the be the
potential for it to be the most rapid
transformation of a space
into to give us more secondary places um
because the head of the school does
think that that could be turned around
very quickly to to to give three
potentially 300 more more places and
that area the area and this is goes for
nor for ultr college as well this area
our area B Oldfield brow hail barns a
lot of children for years have been
going to nutsford which is really quite
a long way away it's not particularly
sustainable for kid you know for kids to
go there to expand the local capacity
will actually give kids chance a lot
more kids kids a chance who were
previously going to nut um you know a
chance to go to a genuinely local
schools so I think if we can get the two
it would be brilliant so I appreciate
the efforts that are being made on North
krian part and alteran college um I
think we all know we're in the hands of
the nuns at the moment whilst they
decide who they're going to sell it to
it's it's good that we have an asset of
community value application is we uh and
therefore you know at least there that
hopefully will buy some time for for
something to be put
together okay thank you everyone um very
thurough conversation there about school
places and the trials and tribulations
thereof right the council Carter sent
out all the recommendations at the start
of this report all those in favor thank
you that moves on to item 15 urgent
business of which I have none so I'm
therefore going to close the meeting and
invite executive members to join me in
room 12 now so thank you very much
everyone enjoy the rest of your
evening
[Music]
e